was genau macht Leute erfolgreich und
warum
was für ein Typ Mensch muss man
eigentlich sein um Millionär zu werden
fest steht in Deutschland wollen
ziemlich viele ziemlich reich sein
[Musik]
heute das Thema schnell reich werden wer
möchte mehr Geld verdienen
rund 7 Millionen spielen regelmäßig
Lotto trotz echt mieser Aussichten auf
den Jackpot es muss also auch anders
Klappen in Deutschland haben wir
mittlerweile 1,2 Millionen Millionäre
durch Arbeit oder Glück welche Klischees
über die Reichen treffen so es war nicht
leicht fünf Menschen zu finden die über
all das ganz offen sprechen so wie
deiner Schweiger vierfachmutter Business
Frau herausgetreten aus dem Schatten
ihres exs Til Schweiger die erste
Million ist immer die schwerster sie
zeigt wie sie heute lebt und wie sie mit
ihren Kindern über Geld redet Fleiß und
Disziplin sind sein Rezept Uwe Schöder
vielen besser bekannt als Internetstar
flying Uwe ich hatte damals zwei
Möglichkeiten entweder verkaufen wir
auch Drogen oder ich hätte den
wesentlich schwierigen Weg gehen können
und zwar fleißig sein er fing an als
Maler ist heute Boss einer kann es jeder
schaffen in Deutschland oder läuft's
meist so wie bei Wolfgang grub sein
Vermögen von geschätzten 100 Millionen
Euro wird vererbt wir haben auch einen
Hubschrauber das ist aber kein
Status-Symbol die Kinder stehen schon
bereit doch nur einer darf die Firma
führen hat der Vater bestimmt ja gut
dann müssen meine Kinder entscheiden
Firma oder Liebe
unglaubliche Geld geht heutzutage auch
unglaublich schnell so wie bei Tim
Schecker von den elevator Boys
so leute wir hatten ja ein Spielzeug
seine 40 Millionen Follower bringen ihn
geschätzt 100.000 Euro pro Monat ich
finde Deutschland ist keine Nation die
anderen Erfolg können
Anna Alex erfolgreicher
start-up-gründerin meint genau deswegen
wird das Thema Geld in Deutschland oft
totgeschwiegen ist das sinnvoll
wahrscheinlich eher nicht deswegen finde
ich es gut mal drüber zu reden
wir bringen diese fünf an einem Tisch
zusammen und blicken hinter die Kulissen
ihres Kontostands entschlüsseln
[Musik]
Wolfgang grub ist Textilunternehmer Chef
von Trigema auch bekannt als die Firma
mit dem werbeaffen
der Heli ist für grob ein Arbeitsgerät
sagt er ein teures
Anschaffungskosten etwa 2,5 Millionen
Euro
[Musik]
also normal wären sie jetzt 2025 Minuten
weniger als 10 braucht der Hubschrauber
für grob zählt jede Minute wir dürfen
ihn dabei begleiten wie er sein neues
Auto in Empfang nimmt
Vollausstattung weißes Leder auch ein
teures Arbeitsgerät wie teuer genau
erfahren wir nicht
extra Wunsch
umgedrehter Beifahrersitz so hat der
Chef hinten mehr Platz
nach vorne lassen was muss ich
unterschreiben
unnötiger Luxus sei das alles nicht
sondern praktisch betont Wolfgang Grupp
bezahlt hat das Auto die Firma des
81-jährigen in der sein ganzes Vermögen
steckt
hier gab es mal 26 Textilfabrikanten
dann haben sie ihre Arbeitsplätze ins
Ausland verlagern und am Schluss sind
sie Konkurs gegangen und ich bin halt
übrig geblieben und dann hat irgendeiner
den Spruch gemacht König von Burladingen
[Musik]
eine kleine Stadt in Schwaben 12.000
Einwohner ein Bekannter Unternehmer
[Musik]
mein Name ist Wolfgang Grupp ich bin
Inhaber der Firma Trigema ich bin in der
dritten Generation und habe die
Verantwortung für 1.200 Mitarbeiter er
ist ein Unternehmer der alten Schule
schreibt keine E-Mails sondern greift
lieber zum Telefon ja kein Problem
danke bitte tschüss
als einziger in der Runde konnte er sein
Erfolg auf ein Erbe auf
ich bin ja aufgewachsen im Betrieb ich
bin ja über die Straßen dann bin ich zu
Hause oder im Betrieb und ich saß einer
Näherin auf dem Schoß mit sechs Jahren
und die hat mir schon gesagt du gibst
halt den zukünftigen Chef
später übernahm er die Firma und einen
Schuldenberg grob hat daraus eine
Erfolgstory gemacht anpacken und nicht
jammern dieses Credo kennt er von
Kindheit an
man hat gehorcht unter Vater war
natürlich auch sehr streng ich wollte
mal ein Moped dann hat mein Vater gesagt
das gibt es nicht da hätte ich nie von
meinem Sparbuch sagen dürfen das kaufe
ich wenn die Eltern gesagt haben das
Moped bekommst du nicht dann durfte ich
es nie vom eigenen Geld kaufen
grob Junior wurde nicht nur im Job ein
Mann mit strengen Prinzipien Schulden
machen für private Dinge würde er
niemals machen sagt er
[Musik]
vielleicht auch das ein Rezept für
Reichtum
und bis heute führt er die Firma obwohl
er längst im Ruhestand sein könnte
[Musik]
aber grob mag die Kontrolle und zeigt
sich gerne als Vorzeigeunternehmer
[Musik]
ich möchte mal so sagen ich bin kein
sozialsäußler ich will Geld verdienen
und mir soll es gut gehen aber Reichtum
verpflichtet auch ich glaube das ist
ganz schön wichtig in einer Firma die
Anerkennung zu gehen das ist ganz
wichtig und ich sag mal wenn ich die
Chance habe dass ich durch meine
Mitarbeiter im Prinzip etwas mehr
verdiene dann habe ich aber auch die
Verpflichtung und die Verantwortung für
meine Mitarbeiter und je mehr man
reicher ist und desto mehr Verantwortung
und so muss man übernehmen was so schön
klingt ist ein Dauerbrenner in
politischen Debatten und beschäftigt
auch immer wieder die Forschung Reichtum
und Verantwortung gegenüber ja wem
eigentlich
Thomas Ruin und Christian Neuhauser
forschen genau zu diesen Fragen
[Musik]
ich glaube jeder der reich ist muss sich
auf einer moralischen Ebene fragen wie
viel von den Reichtum er oder sich für
sich selbst behalten wollen und wie viel
sie mit der Gesellschaft teilen wollen
die erste Million oder die ersten fünf
verändern natürlich eine Lebenssituation
das hat aber damit zu tun von wo komme
ich bin ich Kind einer
milliardärsfamilie bin ich Kind an der
multimillionärsfamilie ist es mein
eigenes Geld habe ich selbst verdient
habe ich im Lotto gewonnen all das
spielt eine Rolle was ist mit einem
macht
grob hat eine soziale Stiftung und
erhaftet mit seinem Privatvermögen
deshalb sei auch niemanden neidisch auf
seinen Erfolg sein Leben stellte er in
den Dienst von T-Shirts erst mit knapp
50 hat er Zeit für sowas wie Familie ich
war 46 Jahre Junggeselle ich habe dann
zwar gesagt egal ich muss auch eine
Familie gründen ich kann erfolgreich im
Geschäft sein wenn ich keine Familie
gründe dann hätte ich versagt aber immer
gesagt egal wie alt ich bin meine Frau
muss Anfang 20 sein
und nun geht es um die Thronfolge
bonita oder Wolfgang Junior
meine Kinder da gibt es keine Diskussion
werden selbstverständlich die Nachfolge
antreten und das die Kinder sagen das
will ich nicht das gibt's nicht das ist
alles eine Erziehungsfrage von klein auf
[Musik]
also wir sind immer mit aufgewachsen mit
dieser Verantwortung und ich glaube aber
auch die Freude überwiegt da auch weil
ich glaube er seine riesen Chance auch
in eine Unternehmerfamilie rein geboren
sein zu dürfen und das auch versuchen zu
dürfen weiter zu führen und wenn wir
dann immer ans Studium auch zurückdenken
und dort BWL studiert haben weil es dort
immer hätten viele davon geträumt so
eine Chance zu haben eine elitäre Chance
[Musik]
rund 20.000 deutsche nennen ein Vermögen
von 30 Millionen Euro oder mehr ihr
eigen rund die Hälfte von ihnen hat das
Vermögen geerbt oder auf eine Erbschaft
aufgebaut
so wird es auch bei Familie grob laufen
auf den Chefsessel darf allerdings nur
eines der Kinder welches das entscheiden
die Eltern
es sollte nur ein Kind die Firma führen
damit sie sich ein Leben lang lieben
beide können in der Firma arbeiten aber
eine muss es gehören damit er auf seinem
Rücken die Entscheidung trifft was ist
dann aber jetzt ich wäre jetzt ihr kennt
ihr so würde aber sagen ich will aber
gerne Pilot werden hätten sie denn aus
ihrer sich was falsch gemacht ja gut
dann hätte ich was falsch gemacht die
Eltern sind natürlich das erste Vorbild
das ist doch ganz die sind ja am
nächsten an den Kindern dran klar ich
habe das Gefühl dass ich über die
Generation das gewandelt hat das
heutzutage immer mehr Kinder nicht mehr
genau das gleiche machen wie die Eltern
sondern eher in ganz andere Richtung
theoretisch gehen wie zum Beispiel
früher wo mehr Kinder noch direkter den
Eltern quasi in den Berufsweg auch
gefolgt sind
die natürlich eine ein Geschäft haben
eine Basis haben dann ist das natürlich
die Eigenständigkeit ist ja schon eine
große Ehre mit diesem stolz von den
Kinder man so mitgehe weil ich finde
also ich und mein Mann haben uns
entschieden für unsere Kinder unsere
Kinder
aufwachsen zu lassen mit möglichst wenig
Erwartungen also das heißt ich möchte
mich eigentlich selbst disziplinieren
nicht irgendwann von meinen Kindern zu
erwarten selbst Unternehmer zu werden
mein Name ist Anna Alex bin seit über
zehn Jahren Unternehmerin ich habe schon
zwei Unternehmen gegründet zuerst Outfit
Rey und dann planetley
zumindest ihr erstes Start-up kennen
viele modeberatung übers Internet und
kurz danach kommt ein klamottenpaket per
Post eine Idee mit der Anna ihr
Durchbruch gelang
aufgewachsen ist sie in bescheidenen
Verhältnissen
ich komme aus Hamburg ursprünglich ich
bin in erster Linie mit meiner Mutter
aufgewachsen also geballte Frauenpower
das war für mich ein wichtiger Teil und
das hat mich sehr geprägt
erfolgreich zu sein war für mich wichtig
in erster Linie weil es für meine Mutter
immer wichtig war und viel geritten in
meiner Jugend und dann konnte ich nicht
einfach nur reiten weil es schön war und
weil ich die Natur genießen wollte
sondern dann bin ich direkt auf Turniere
geschickt worden wo ich nach mehreren
Jahren aber jetzt auch dankbar dafür bin
dass sie mir da so einen gewissen Drive
mit auf den Weg gegeben hat
[Musik]
nach dem Studium bin ich relativ schnell
in die Berliner Start-up-Szene
reingekommen als das aber noch überhaupt
gar kein anerkannter Karriereweg war ich
fand das aber halt von einem Tag eins an
großartig den Spirit der so in der
Start-up-Szene herrscht Leute die was
anpacken wollen die was umsetzen da wird
nicht viel geredet da wird gemacht und
das ist bis heute das was meine
Leidenschaft ist etwas zu schaffen aus
dem Nichts wo vorher nichts war wo
vorher eine grüne Wiese war ein
Unternehmen zu bauen weil sie hat auf
einer Idee
das gibt mir unglaublich viel Energie
also ich glaube meine Mutter und auch
meine Rest meiner Familie die waren eher
besorgt als ich gesagt habe ich gehe
jetzt in die Startup-Szene das sind
kleine Unternehmen die kriegen von
Investoren Geld komisch wo konnten
dieses Geld irgendwie eigentlich her
9,9 Milliarden Euro wurden 2022 in
Deutschland ins Startups investiert aber
nur 20% aller startup-gründer sind
weiblich auch deshalb rangieren Frauen
bei Einkommen und Vermögen noch immer
weit hinter Männern
von meinem ersten signifikanten Geld
damals habe ich meiner Mutter ein
kleines Haus auf dem Land gekauft ich
wollte meiner Mutter eine Freude machen
und ich wusste dass sie sich alleine nie
wird leisten können
Kinderzimmer
ich versuche keine Erwartungen an meine
Kinder zu haben gerade weil meine Mutter
an mich viele Erwartungen hatte und ich
viele Jahre gebraucht habe bis ich das
verstanden habe welche Erwartung meine
Mutter eigentlich an mich hat und dass
ich nicht da bin um die Erwartung meiner
Mutter zu erfüllen sondern dass ich da
bin nur mein eigenes Leben zu leben
[Musik]
Menschen die Millionäre geworden sind
gelten laut Studien als risikobereiter
im Vergleich zur Allgemeinbevölkerung
so wir sind uns wahrscheinlich bewusster
darüber dass das die Lebenszeit begrenzt
ist und das ist unsere tägliche
Lebenszeit ist die wir dafür etwas
hergeben ich habe das Gefühl dass unsere
Generation sehr geprägt also zumindest
von
man muss erfolgreich sein und jetzt gibt
es um
genau andersrum weil
mein Elternhaus oder mein Elternhaus
sehr fokussiert auf Arbeit um eben den
Kindern ein gutes Leben zu ermöglichen
aber das hatte das Resultat dass mein
Dad der aus der Bankenwelt kommt in
meiner Kindheit eigentlich nur
gearbeitet hat und am Wochenende auch
immer größer und wenn man Urlaub
gefahren sind ist Muster oftmals
zurückfliegen hin und her oder so das
sozusagen ich eigentlich von meinem
Vater in mein Kindheit so meine
Ehrlichkeit sehr nicht nicht sehr viel
von hatte der ich ich kann sich abwarten
einmal die Frau meiner Träume zu
heiraten mit ihrer Familie zu gründen
also und das dann in der Lage bin mit
meinen Kindern so viel Zeit wie es geht
zu verbringen
wäre eigentlich ein Traum dass er jetzt
in den Jungen in den jungen Jahren jetzt
sehen wir durch
der Jüngste in der Runde heißt Tim
Schecker Vertreter der Generation z
ja das ist gut was cool Geld verdienen
im Internet so würden es die älteren
vielleicht nennen die Jüngeren sprechen
von Content Creator auf Deutsch Inhalte
erschaffen
[Musik]
ein aufzugsvideo hat die fünf Jungs
weltweit bekannt gemacht
seitdem stellen sie fast täglich neue
Clips ins Netz
Abrufzahlen 2 Milliarden viele Views
viele Follower viel Geld so lautet die
Gleichung
[Musik]
zwei Monate in Amerika wo sie zum
Beispiel mit Heidi klumfahrstuhl
gefahren sind ich würde sagen wir sind
genauso
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt gerade Brad Pitt auf
einer Filmpremiere getroffen der wusste
wer wir sind und mit ihm ein Video eben
im Aufzug gedreht
weltweiter Rom brachte schon immer viel
Geld verändert hat sich die
Geschwindigkeit
zusammen haben wir ungefähr 40 Millionen
Follower auf tiktok würde ich sagen wenn
alle unsere Instagram Accounts
zusätzlich haben wir ein Youtube Account
mit einer halben Millionen also
irgendwie eine ganze ganze Menge Leute
so die einen schon mal gesehen haben
von jetzt auf gleich ein Star vorher
waren die fünf Studenten oder hatten
erste Jobs
nun stürzen sich nicht nur Fans auf sie
egal wo Sie gerade sind sondern große
Unternehmen bezahlen die elevator Boys
als Werbeträger so leute wir hatten
immer blau man sehr viele diese
Umhängetasche und ja die Bilder
so ein Handy freien Tag gab es
eigentlich seit zwei Jahren für mich
glaube ich nicht mehr
wo verdienen sie jetzt oder wer bezahlt
sie jetzt das geschäftsunter ist dass
wir mit Firmen zusammenarbeiten wir die
die und wir Produktplatzierung im
Endeffekt um platzieren dann ein Produkt
in ihrem Podcast genau und dafür zahlt
der also wert dafür bezahlte
Werbepartner genau die die
Werbeplattform von von heute ist es gibt
kaum noch Fernsehwerbung E-Mail-Werbung
all diese all diese Budgets fließen
heutzutage eben mit Social Media
Marketing
geschätzte 5 bis 10.000 € verdienen
Social Media Stars
wen wundert dass inzwischen viele junge
Leute von so einem Beruf träumen
unsere Eltern haben uns supportet eben
wo sie konnten es gibt keine sehr keine
Geldnöte oder so zu haben der Einfluss
des Elternhauses in vielerlei Hinsicht
oft ein entscheidender Karrierefaktor
aber einfach mal zurücklehnen und auf
die Uhr live Balance achten das reicht
nicht oftmals geht bei uns der
Arbeitstag bis spät in die Nacht rein
meistens haben wir direkt morgens
Meetings um zu schauen was es gibt zu
Update was gibt's für neue
Kooperationsanfragen und dann geht's
meistens schon die ersten Termine rein
allerdings der Aufzug fährt nach oben
genauso schnell wie nach unten das
Geschäftsmodell die Reichweite die man
hat eben zu nutzen
Reichweite bringt Verantwortung deshalb
engagiert sich die Truppe gegen Mobbing
im Netz
aber Reichweite bringt vor allem Geld
ein mehrköpfiges Management-Team lots
die elevator Boys durch die Glamour Welt
die Welle so lange reiten wie es geht
denn hier gelten andere Regeln als in
der normalen Arbeitswelt Reisen Autos
Kleidung gibt es einfach so mit
Promi-Status andere müssen lange dafür
schuften und selbst dann reicht das Geld
manchmal nicht
wir sind jetzt gerade in Mailand wir
sind vorhin angekommen ich bin gestern
nach Berlin gefahren nachts noch gepackt
und dann morgens direkt zum Airport ist
mir gerade meine angekommen wir müssen
jetzt auch schon weiter aber in einer
Stunde in einer Stunde geht unsere erste
Show los ich habe dich lieb
und seine Freunde leben inzwischen in
einer eigenen Welt
gegenüber anderen müssen Sie Ihren
Erfolg häufig rechtfertigen
für den Außenstehenden kann ich komplett
verstehen dass er sagt eine million
views Personen scheiß toll weiter aber
generell ist es doch so dass wenn einer
eine Idee hat wo er viele mit begeistert
die ihm folgen ob das dann Mist ist oder
nicht er hat viele begeistert und die
Zahlen gerne und dann kann er ja auch
Geld verdienen Leistung ist ja sehr
subjektiv also zu bewerten zu sagen das
ist jetzt ein Leistung die das und das
wert ist ist ja total subjektiv
welcher Lohn ist gerecht und wie weit
darf eine Gehaltsschere in einer
Gesellschaft auseinander gehen dazu
forscht Jutta Allmendinger
in Deutschland sagten die meisten
Leistung muss ich lohnen wenn alle jetzt
das gleiche verdienen würden das würde
niemand ertragen wollen aber
leistungsgerecht wird unsere
Gesellschaft von 84% auch nicht
angesehen heute gibt es Berufe in denen
man Reichtum generieren kann wie
Influenza
etc das wäre vor 15 Jahren völlig
undenkbar gewesen und denkbar das kam
für ihn nie in Frage immer an sich
glauben trotz mieser stark Bedingungen
mit diesem Motto wurde er reich mein
Name ist Uwe Schüler bin jetzt 35 Jahre
alt bin gelernter Maler und Lackierer
dann rüber zu YouTube Social Media ich
bin's wieder euer fly Uwe und jetzt bin
ich Unternehmer mit fünf Firmen müssten
das sein genau
ja das bin ich
[Musik]
das ist mein persönliches Büro mit
meinen Jungs das ist mein Platz kann man
direkt erkennen ich bin nicht so der
ordentlichste Typ aber das sind ja
kreative Menschen halt
vom Maler zum Millionär das ist die
Story von Uwe Schüler
längst hat er den Pinsel beiseite gelegt
heute verkauft er mit zwei Partnern
Energy Drinks Tees
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel und
Sportbekleidung
in seinem Headquarter ist auch viel
Platz für Fotoshootings denn Uwe ist ein
online-star
jetzt zwei Szenen geschickt dass ich sie
in meinen Stories mit reinpacken kann so
wissen die Zuschauer das wird das
nächste Video cool war ein bisschen
Spannung aufbauen und dann können sie
aufs nächste Video freuen
Uwe ist ein Aushängeschild seiner Marken
mit seiner Bekanntheit bewirbt er seine
Produkte sein YouTube-Kanal hat 2
Millionen Abonnenten
[Musik]
familiär gesehen was nicht so toll denn
meine Eltern haben damals ja so ein
Drogengeschäft gehabt am drogenverkauft
das war wie ein Unternehmen ne also mein
Stiefvater war der Chef und seine ganzen
Kollegen waren die Läufer die dann
rausgegangen sind und die ganzen Drogen
verkauft haben ja ich habe damals mein
Stiefvater bewunder weil der hat echt
ein also wenn man das jetzt
unternehmerisch betrachtet ein gutes
Business gehabt so von der Struktur her
und er lief halt immer mit sehr viel
Bargeld rum und ich habe auch als ich
klein war mal eben so unter meine
Matratze 30 000 D-Mark gefunden und so
und da dachte ich so auch okay ich
möchte auch später mal viel Geld
verdienen aber nicht mit dem schlechten
Wege so
[Musik]
ich war immer so das drogenkind und die
Eltern wollten mich manchmal nicht
reinlassen und ich meine Freunde besucht
habe und so weiter musste auch draußen
warten wie so ein duli so bis er
rauskommt und so
fleißig
ausgegrenzt
empelt für viele wäre der Weg
vorgezeichnet
meine Mutter sagt damals beim Laterne
laufen mit der Schule einfach im Stehen
an der Ampel eingepennt weil sie war ja
selber dann drogenabhängig
[Musik]
dann sind wir auch umgezogen und da habe
ich dann gemerkt so oh jetzt läuft es
richtig schief so
Begegnung mit dem alten Leben
und hier war mein Fenster das war mein
Zimmer genau dort sechs Quadratmeter
dieses Zimmer sehr gesund ganz kleines
Zimmer ein Schrank hat hingepasst
kleiner Schreibtisch und auf der anderen
Seite dann keiner schreibt wo mein
Fernseher drauf war kein Teppich drin
nichts wir sind eingezogen und haben
dann einfach so gelebt da und da wo auch
mit Essen das Essen wurde Essen wurde
knapp das muss man sich immer reinziehen
so weil das Geld immer für Drogen
draufgehen
die damaligen Nachbarn erleben alles mit
sehen nicht nur zu sondern informieren
das Jugendamt
[Musik]
mensch
das ist von hier drüben von Angelo Leon
Uwe und alle Drogenabhängigkeit damals
ist seinen Ausweg findet Uwe auf
Videokassetten er flüchtet sich in die
Welt des Bruce Lee
unbesiegbar unbeirrbar
ich hatte so halt mein Standpunkt im
Kopf wie ich sein wollte
ich wollte so sein wie Bruce Lee das war
so mein kindheits-ding
die Sache ist ja wenn man an eine Sache
glaubt zieht man es einfach durch man
tut es einfach
bei seinem alten Kung Fu Meister
Uwe strengt sich an beim Sport und in
seinem Leben
sein mein Set ein unbändiger Wille immer
besser zu sein und Probleme zu lösen
aber uwe hat hier noch die Umkleide
Damen Herrn Duschen geworden
und ich weiß aber auch dass er statt
Beiträge zu bezahlen Fußleisten gemalt
hat
das darf man nicht unterschätzen
mein erstes Geld habe ich mir
tatsächlich mit dem Handwerk verdient
man und Lackierer keine Entscheidung aus
Leidenschaft sondern weil es das war was
der Schulabschluss hergab
als Lehrling habe ich verdient im ersten
Lehrjahr ich weiß gar nicht mehr 180
Euro dann war es irgendwie 230 und im
dritten Wasser 380 Euro oder so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wusste so ich will den kurz arbeiten
und dann will ich was ganz anderes
machen will ich mein eigenes Ding machen
[Musik]
schreibt man in den Kommentaren was ihr
als nächstes sehen wollt
als ich dann mein erstes Geld mit die
Youtube verdient habe ja mann das war
erstmal so ein paar 100 € wurde das halt
immer mehr eineinhalb tausend Euro aber
2000 € boah cool und so es lag ja an
meinem Content wie viel Videos ich
gebracht habe bin ich gut durchgezogen
habe dann kam auch regelmäßig Geld rein
wenn ich das Video gefallen hat meine
Freundin gibt natürlich einen Daumen
nach oben denn Support und wir sehen uns
zum nächsten Video
moin leute ich bin's wieder euer flying
Uwe ich wollte ein berühmter Mann werden
jo was geht alles klar und ich wollte
ganz viel Geld verdienen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
finanziell jetzt also ja ich bin echt
fühle mich ich bin reich kann man ich
finde ich bin reich ja genau heute ist
es eher so bei mir wenn ich jetzt meinen
Sport Auto oder was auch immer so ich
mir ist es unangenehm mittlerweile da
irgendwo mit zu sein so also es ist bei
mir so ich bin letztens erste Klasse
geflogen und ich dachte mir so okay das
geht jetzt schon ich muss links rein und
die müssen rechts und ich dachte mein
Geschäftspartner guck dir mal an das ist
noch Klassen gibt so was Menschen
betrifft die müssen da rein und wir hier
so ich dachte mir so ist das richtig was
ich hier mache so das war ein bisschen
so aber einerseits dachte ich habe sie
auch verdient also das ist genau also
man muss ja dem einzelnen auch zugeben
dass er für sein hart verdientes Geld
das kaufen kann was ihm Spaß macht dann
darf man das auch mit Stolz zeigen dann
gibt's auch kein Leid ist das so
Bewunderung oder Neid wie gehen wir als
Gesellschaft mit dem finanziellen Erfolg
andere Raum
Deutschland als Neidgesellschaft ist
natürlich eine Pauschalisierung
wir sind eine vorwitzige Gesellschaft
die gerne guckt was andere machen vor
jeder Bundestagswahl versuchen alle
Parteien so ein bisschen
reichtumsschelte zu betreiben weil die
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung ist nicht ist
ja es ist schöner reiche durchs Dorf zu
jagen als jetzt besondere Leistungen
hervorzuheben wenn sich eine bestimmte
Gruppe von Menschen
teure Autos schöne Altbauwohnungen oder
eben wunderbare Weltreisen leisten und
letztlich aber genauso viel arbeiten und
wie andere und die anderen sich das aber
überhaupt nicht leisten können dann sind
diese anderen glaube ich nicht neidisch
sondern in ihrem Gerechtigkeitssinn zu
Recht verletzt wir haben sehr viele
Kinder die quasi schon mit Geburt
Immobilien große einkommensmengen große
Vermögenswerte haben und eigentlich gar
nicht mehr erwerbstätig sein müssen das
ist sozusagen mit dieser goldene Löffel
und dann steht man natürlich da mit dem
gedrückten Rücken und sagt das kann man
ja sowieso nicht erreichen vollkommen
ohne erreichbar
eine ostdeutsche Biografie ein
Migrationshintergrund kein Mann sein
alleinerziehend ein Elternhaus ohne Geld
all das Faktoren die Reichtum in
Deutschland deutlich unwahrscheinlicher
machen
unwahrscheinlich aber nicht unmöglich
ich versuche schon meine Kinder so zu
erziehen dass wenn die Geld haben wollen
müssen wir auch was tun dafür also
[Musik]
Beispiel haben wir damit angefangen dass
wenn die Taschengeld kriegen will haben
will muss sie erstmal ihr Zimmer
aufräumen sie kriegt viel Besuch und das
Zimmer sieht aus wie Sau du möchtest 5
Euro haben dann rollen das Zimmer auf
kriegst du 5 €, dann kannst du da noch
mal kaufen kannst du das kaufen gehen
und das macht sie dann halt auch
[Musik]
er hat auch schon so seine Vision gehabt
und lässt sich davon auch 0,0
so gar nicht ne also er weiß immer was
er was er will wo er hin will und das
zieht er dann durch die hat auch eine
Disziplin dieser Mann das ist
unglaublich
das ist ein kinderseil jetzt und mein
Ehrgeiz ist jetzt trotzdem das mit dem
Kinderserie zu schaffen
[Applaus]
mein Kindern würde ich auf jeden Fall
sagen dass ich jetzt schon meine große
Tochter die soll immer auf ihr
Kinderherz hören sie soll immer darauf
hören was sie will und was sie gerne in
der Fantasie hätte also man soll immer
auf sein Herz hören genau
[Musik]
cool sehr sehr cool ich finde das ist
ein ganz ganz wichtiger Aspekt
eigentlich noch mal zu überlegen wo man
den herkommt bei Leistung ist das eine
aber die Voraussetzung sind häufig halt
auch ganz ganz andere in diesem Rahmen
dann Leistung zu schaffen und du hast es
gerade uns erzählt in deinem Video du
hattest nicht den goldenen Löffel im
Mund als Kind du hast dir das von da
selber erarbeitet viele schaffen das von
dort aber auch nicht weil dir einfach
woanders anfangen so im Rennen des
Lebens warum hast du es geschafft und
andere nicht warum machen es andere
nicht ich habe einfach mein Leben in die
Hand genommen und dann was unternommen
und meiner Meinung nach ja
kann das auch irgendwie jeder klar je
nachdem was für ein mindset wer was hat
so aber die Stärke besitzt aber ich muss
das halt auch tun und deswegen sage ich
auch so wenn ich das kann dann kannst du
es auch versuche es machen
den Spruch vom tellerwäsche zu Millionär
das war ja typisch in Amerika dass man
und das das ist immer abhängig vom von
einzelnen und ich glaube das nicht was
sie sagen dass man sagt wenn man nicht
in die goldener wiege geboren ist dass
man dann keine Chancen hat wenn man eine
Leistung bringt dann bringt man es vom
Tellerwäscher zum Millionär man muss es
nur bringen und muss man es nur bringen
ist es so einfach gleiche Chancen für
alle und Leistung wird belohnt das ist
eine Illusion sagt Philosoph Christian
Neuhauser es gibt
hundertellerwäscherinnen und einer oder
eine davon wird Millionär und in der 99
bleiben übrig und das war schon immer so
und auch das hat mit Glücksfaktoren
zu tun ja alle versuchen irgendwas zu
machen und eine Person hat halt Glück
und hinzu kommt dass das Bildungswesen
ja zwischen auch von direkten
finanziellen Leistungen abhängig ist
also man kann sich an Eliteuniversitäten
auf der Welt Einkaufen man kann sich
Master of Business Administration
gewissermaßen für 100000 € kaufen und
das hat dann erheblichen Einfluss darauf
welche Karrierewege offen steht das Geld
häuft sich bei denen auf die schon mit
Geld geboren wurden als Kind die dann
auch noch in Partnerschaften gehen mit
anderen Geld haben und wo man natürlich
als normaler Mensch sagt da komme ich
erst gar nicht hin und dieses da komme
ich erst gar nicht hin schafft keine
motivationale Basis vom tellerwäsche so
Millionär aufzusteigen keine Motivation
keine Chance oder doch alles eine Frage
des Willens
wo habt ihr eigentlich euren Antrieb
entwickelt so was ist der Antrieb warum
machen wir ja alle was wir machen sind
nicht nur total interessante Frage
muss ich sagen also hat ganz viel mit
meiner Mutter zu tun weil meine Mutter
aber meine Vater ist in den schweren
Unfall gewesen und meine Mutter musste
Geld verdienen und sie hat
zwei Firmen und unsere Keller aufgebaut
[Musik]
ich bin aufgewachsen in Sierra
Washington zusammen mit meiner Schwester
und meine Eltern
[Musik]
und unsere Familie immer gewesen du bist
was du tust
also tu auch was lautete das Motto im
Elternhaus von deiner Schweiger
[Musik]
meine Mutter hat gesagt du kriegst bei
uns ein Zuhause du kriegst was zu essen
du kriegst eine bestimmte Summe für
klamaten und alles anders müsste für
sich selbst sorgen ich habe ziemlich
schnell gecheckt dass ich muss zwei Jobs
arbeiten um alles hinzukriegen ich habe
damals hardware store gearbeitet es
Kassierer und dann auch in einen Dalli
ich habe jeden Tag gearbeitet also
Sonntag bis Sonntag und könnte trotzdem
meinen Universität nicht leisten
aber auf die Karriere an der Kasse folgt
eine als Model
Anfang der 90er Jahre kommt Dana das
erste Mal nach Deutschland mit folgen
so ich habe gemadelt in Deutschland
damals und habe den Titel kennengelernt
und wir haben ziemlich schnell
geheiratet in vier Kinder bekommen und
da bin ich ziemlich schnell Mutter
geworden
irgendwo da drin hat eine Freundin mich
gefragt aber ich irgendwie Lust habe
eine Firma zu gründen und ich habe
sofort abgelehnt und gesagt nein ich
will nur Mutter sein ich will nicht
irgendwie dass meine Kinder von nanis
aufgewachsen sind und
irgendwie ist es doch dazu gegangen
und da haben wir angefangen damals mit
organic Pflege für Kindern und
Schwangere mit Schauspielerin Ursula
Karven gründet sie ein Label für
Kosmetik und Kleidung die Firma wird
schnell bekannt die Prominenz hilft
[Musik]
für Reichtum braucht es nämlich mehr als
eine gute Idee sagt Philosoph Christian
Neuhauser Erfolg braucht die richtigen
Kontakte
alle so genannten selfmade Millionär
sind mit Millionär sondern die haben
Netzwerke gehabt die ihn geholfen haben
und dafür können die Leute werden nichts
das sind einfach zufälliger soziale
Zufälle die dafür sind es einige
wahnsinnig reich werden und andere nicht
[Musik]
das ist meine Jüngste Tag der immer war
immer meine Kleine Helferin die ist die
einer von meine Kinder die den immer
gleich reinspringt ohne rum zu meckern
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
da habe ich schon in Italien bestellt
in Venedig dafür dass es alles extra
angefertigt ist es fand ich nicht so
übertrieben teuer das war so ein 1800
das war jetzt nie so dass wir irgendwie
in der Familie besprochen haben ihr seid
reich oder was besseres oder irgendwie
ist es wichtig im Geld im Leben Geld zu
haben also das war auf jeden Fall nie
ein Thema bei uns wir haben immer H&M
getragen in Zara wie alle anderen
Kindern
unsere Kinder sind nicht ähm rumgelaufen
mit gerade im Gucci und sowas
gepotzt wird nicht Geld verdient aber
trotzdem
die erste Million ist immer die
schwerste im Wirtschaft und auch privat
würde ich auch sagen wenn man das äh
einmal erreicht hat dann kann man
natürlich Geld nutzen was man hat um
sich weiterzuentwickeln
[Musik]
jetzt im Moment mein
Hauptprojekt ist mein Gasthaus in
Marburg was ich Vermieter das Ferienhaus
das hier ist meine zweite Heimat
Malibu am Pazifik eine Stunde von Los
Angeles Wohnort der Schönen und Reichen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und der Ort wo Dana ihr Geld für sich
arbeiten lässt das Haus am Pazifik ist
mehr als ein Zweitwohnsitz es ist auch
ein Renditeobjekt diesmal
businessmäßig für mich weil ich muss das
Haus anschauen neue Fotos davon machen
und gucken dass alles was wir haben
wirklich perfekt sitzt für die Gästen
hier lebte Dana auch eine Zeit lang mit
Til Schweiger und den Kindern
nach der Scheidung hat sie das
Familiendomizil behalten und den Ex
ausbezahlt
[Musik]
und die Frage ist ob wir die erste Gold
bestellt
die Villa ist über eine Online-Plattform
zu mieten das Haus ist 2500 pro Nacht es
klingt teuer aber wenn man überlegt dass
man 12 Leute nicht unterbringen kann für
2500 in einem Hotel dann ist es in
Verhältnis bei der ich schon sagen die
Wille im Moment ich weiß nicht so ganz
genau was es wert ist aber es wird
geschätzt zwischen sechs und acht
Millionen wann braucht man eigentlich
nicht mehr selbst zu arbeiten wann er
arbeitet das eigene Vermögen genug
studien haben gezeigt dass das Vermögen
etwa das 25-fache der jährlichen
Ausgaben betragen muss damit man von den
Erträgen leben kann wer jährlich 40.000
€ vor Steuern benötigt käme dann mit
einer Million hin für 100.000 braucht
man schon 2,5 Millionen
sie hat es geschafft
geholfen haben die richtigen
Entscheidungen und die richtigen
Begegnungen
es ist irgendwie interessant zu sehen wo
man anfängt und wo man endet sozusagen
fünf Lebensgeschichten fünf Geschichten
von Geld Menschen die ihr Weg reich
gemacht hat
so kann es funktionieren
ein sicheres Rezept für Wohlstand gibt
es trotzdem nicht
[Musik]
die reicher jemand ist desto weniger hat
das mit eigenen Verdienst mit einer
Leistung zu tun also je reicher ein
Mensch ist desto mehr spielen
Glücksfaktoren eine Rolle über die diese
einzelnen Menschen keine Kontrolle hat
das kann daran liegen dass jemand mit
Talenten geboren ist ne aber Talente hat
man nicht verdient gewissermaßen sondern
hat man Glück gehabt Leute die zu mir
kommen würden und sagen ich möchte
Millionär werden der tut mir leid weil
was das für eine Berufsbeschreibung was
ist das für ein Lebensziel ja ich muss
ja erstmal etwas in mir finden was ich
gerne mache idealerweise was ich kann
weil um Geld zu bekommen muss ich ja
irgendetwas anbieten wenn man so rangeht
dann wird man unter Umständen auch
Millionär
Fleiß Disziplin Leistung all das hilft
bestimmt auch aber für den Eintritt in
den Club der Millionäre zählt vor allem
eins Glück bleibt die Frage macht denn
Geld am Ende eigentlich glücklich Geld
kann Energie sein aber es kommt eben
darauf an wofür man es ausgeht wenn man
für Status Symbole ausgibt und irgendwie
vermeintlich nur noch einen fettere
Karre kauft als der Nachbar dann finde
ich das nicht sinnvoll ich möchte nur
sagen das Schönste im Leben ist ja nicht
täglich sein Geld zu zählen sondern das
Schönste im Leben ist das Gefühl zu
bekommen von seiner Familie und vor
allem von seinen Mitarbeitern noch gerne
gesehen oder gebraucht zu werden Geld
macht im Endeffekt nicht direkt
glücklich es gibt dir nur gewisse
Freiheiten über Dinge und diese Freiheit
ist das erstrebenswerte eigentlich ein
Geld für mich ist ein Dach über den Kopf
was zu essen und dass ich mich
ordentlich anziehen kann dass meine
Kinder gut geht und dass die alle gesund
sind
Geld ist ein cooles Tool womit man sich
geile Sachen erfüllen kann aber das ist
nicht das was glücklich macht sondern
das Drumherum die Menschen die haben
mich glücklich so ja
[Musik]